Well, good morning again, church.
It's always a blessing to get together like this
and worship together, especially with an extra hour
of sleep last night.
Well, I shouldn't say that for everyone.
These new parents didn't get that.
They just, the kid just wakes up an hour earlier.
Uh, and then many of you had the alarm on your phone go off
last night at 2:00 AM So we're all
refreshed and ready to go today.
It's a good day. Uh,
but if you're new to our church,
we're grateful you are here.
We'd love to get to meet you.
There's a QR code on the seat in front of you,
or you can just head out to the new here area out there.
And, uh, just let us know you're here.
We'd love to meet you and get
you some information about our church.
Get to know you a little bit. Uh,
or maybe you've been here a little bit.
Uh, you're, you're seeing like this is
where you wanna plant roots and become a part
of our church family through membership.
Next Sunday evening, we're having
what we call meaningful membership workshop.
It's a way for you to get to know us
and kind of discern what really we are about as a church.
And that would be the first step
towards becoming a member of our church.
So if that's for you, please sign up on the app
or on the website or just out there in the lobby.
Find somebody that can help you do that.
But I wanna start today with a question.
Do you feel worthless to God?
Like, do you feel like you bring nothing to the table?
Especially like compared to other people
and other people in minute?
Like, do you, do you feel worthless to God?
Or maybe that's not you.
Maybe you're on the other side of this.
Maybe you know you have a purpose
and you know that God can use you, but,
but your issue is that you feel like the things
that we face in life are just too great, too overwhelming.
There's no way we can overcome.
Well, either way. This passage in one Samuel will speak
to you today, but not only to you.
It'll also speak to all of us
because it's gonna point us to a battle that only God
can actually win for us.
And that's the point of this narrative today.
So if you're not already there, go ahead
and turn in your copy of God's word to one Samuel
Chapter 13, one Samuel 13.
We continue our He Shall Reign series
through this book of one Samuel.
We're well into it by now.
But last week you remember, we tragically witnessed
Saul's initial disobedience, Which led
to God removing the kingship from his family line, that even
after he is dead, it won't continue In Saul's line,
there's gonna be a new family line
that the king will come from.
And so we saw that begin,
but we also were reminded by that of how futile
their search for a saving king actually was.
Why was it futile? Because they already had a saving king
whose name was Yahweh.
They didn't need another king, but they sure wanted one.
But it was really fruitless.
Well, today's the continuation of that scene.
'cause we're moving now into the battle
with the Philistines.
Remember, they were pressing hard on the people of Israel.
They were terrifying the people of Israel.
And so notice what happened here.
Notice what happened as we go into the narrative again,
remember, many people had run away from Saul.
They were hiding in the mountains.
They were running over the, the river.
They were, they were seeing
that this was a terrifying situation.
And so we continued.
Now starting with the back half of verse 15,
one Samuel 13, verse 15, about halfway
through says this.
And Saul numbered the people who were present with him,
about 600 men.
Now remember they started with 3000,
just a few verses earlier.
Now they're down to 600. Not just men.
Terrified men who were even with Saul still
so clearly the Israelite army got smaller.
It was small to begin with, but it got much smaller.
Like you'd think this massive Philistine armies pressing
and they recruit more troops.
Actually, what happened is they were losing troops.
Instead, ominous.
Not only was their army getting smaller,
the Philistine army was getting closer.
They were getting closer. This threat was increasing
that they were getting smaller on their side.
But the threat was increasing. Watch this happen.
This is verses 16 through 18.
This army gets closer to Saul
and his men, verse 16.
And Saul and Jonathan, his son
and the people who were present with him stayed
in Giba of Benjamin.
But the Philistines had camped in
Mash just a little bit further east from there.
And Raiders came outta the camp
of the Philistines in three companies.
One company turned toward Oprah to the land of swa,
another company toward Beth Horan,
another company toward the border
that looks down on the valley of Zebu
towards the wilderness.
Now, I know some of you have your ancient Israelite
geography just right on the forefront
of your mind all the time.
Uh, but for the rest of us,
lemme explain what you just read.
It really, it's hard to put it on a map.
'cause we don't actually know exactly
where all these places were.
Just think of it this way.
These three companies of the Philistines were trying
to surround Saul.
That's basically what it's saying.
One went here, one went here, one went here just trying
to surround Saul and his army.
Not only that, look at verses 19 through 23 as well.
Now, there were, there was no blacksmith
to be found throughout all the land of Israel.
For the Philistines said,
let the lest the Hebrews make themselves swords or spears.
But every one of the Israelites went down to the Philistines
to sharpen his plowshare, his madoc, his ax or his sickle.
And the charge was two thirds of a shekel
for the Plowshares, for the Maddox, a third of a shekel
for sharpening the axes, for setting the gods.
So on the day of the battle, so we'll get there in a second.
On the day of the battle, there was neither sword
nor spear found in the hand of any of the people with Saul
and Jonathan, except for Saul and Jonathan.
His son had swords.
And the garrison, the Philistines, went out
to the past of Mik Mash.
Some of you have never heard any
of those words before in your life.
Honestly, I just read it and saw Maddock.
I don't even know what that is. Okay, so again,
fascinating words involved in this passage.
Lemme explain what's happening.
There were no metal workers in the land of Israel
because the Philistines controlled metal
production and maintenance.
So what they had done is they had effectively disarmed
Israel completely and put up a picture
of ancient farm tools.
We don't know if this is exactly what they had, but,
but even the farm tools that Israel would've had
to use in their gardens
or in their fields, they had to go
to the Philistines to sharpen them.
And all the prices that you read there,
of course we have no framework for that,
but they were outrageously high prices
like to go get a knife.
Sharpened was like $150, you might say something like that.
It's just extreme.
And what the Philistine, it says it right?
The Philistines were doing was saying, we don't want them
to have swords or anything they could use in battle.
The point is that when the battle would come,
the the Israelites were severely under supplied
because the Philistines not only had swords,
they also had chariots.
And they're over here with like a pocket knife in Israel.
Then you couple that with the fact
that the Philistine army had surrounded them.
And what this is leading us to think about is that Saul,
his, his defeat seemed inevitable.
Remember God had said, Saul, you're going to be judged
for your disobedience.
This is when it's gonna happen.
It sure seems like it, right?
That that God's judgment was coming through the Philistines,
that Saul was gonna finally get what he was deserving of.
But if you recall a new character we met last week in the
narrative, an honorable,
courageous young man named Jonathan.
Jonathan was Saul's son.
And because of Jonathan,
things may actually turn out differently.
Let's see,
because remember, Jonathan was set
in contrast to his father.
Saul and Jonathan were set in contrast
and we'll see it very clearly here.
We're gonna jump into chapter 14.
Now I'm gonna read 15 verses
so we can follow this narrative.
You've set the scene, right?
You know what this is gonna feel like.
You know where we're at in this whole thing.
Now watch chapter 14.
One day, Jonathan, the son of Saul, said to the young man
who carried his armor, come let us go over
to the Philistine Garrison on the other side.
He did not tell his father.
Saul was staying in the outskirts of Gibbon
and the pomegranate cave at mid grand.
The people who were with him were about 600 men, including
Aja, the son of a high tube Kobas brother, son of Phineas,
son of Eli, the priest of the Lord in Shiloh,
wearing an EFA that'll come into play next week.
You'll see that. And the people did not know
that Jonathan had gone within the passes
by which Jonathan sought to go over
to the Philistine garrison.
There was a rocky crack on one side,
a rocky crowd on the other side.
Name of the one was bozo, the name of the other Cena.
The one Craig rose in the north in front of Mash,
the other on the south in front of Giba.
And so set the scene.
It's like a valley, almost a, a kind of a slim way to crab,
to gr go through there.
You'd have to climb hills to get out of it.
That's where we're at. Jonathan said to the young man
who carried his armor, come, let us go over to the garrison
of these uncircumcised.
It may be that the Lord will work for us
for nothing can hinder the Lord from saving
by many or by few.
And his armor said to him, do all that's in your heart.
Do as you wish. Behold, I'm with you, heart and soul.
Then Jonathan said, behold, we'll cross over to the men.
We will show ourselves to them.
If they say to us, wait until we come to you,
then we'll stand still in our place.
We will not go up to them.
But if they say, come up to us, then we'll go up.
For the Lord has given them into our hand.
This shall be the sign for us.
So both of them showed themselves to the garrison
of the Philistines and the Philistines said, look,
Hebrews are coming out of the holes
where they have hidden themselves.
And the minute of the garrison hailed,
Jonathan Armor bears said, come up to us,
will show you a thing.
And Jonathan said to his armor, bearer, come up after me.
The Lord has given them into the hand of Israel.
Then Jonathan climbed up on his hands
and feet, his armor bearer after him and they fell.
The Philistines fell
before Jonathan, his armor bearer killed them after him.
That first strike, which Jonathan's armor bearer made,
killed about 20 men within, as it were a furrows length
and an acre of a land, basically a football field size.
And there was a panic in the camp in the field
among all the people, the garrison
and even the Raiders trembled the earth quaked.
And it became a very great panic.
So did you see what just happened here
in the face of a dire threat, possessing
inferior weaponry, Jonathan trusted the Lord.
You see it? He's way outmatched.
They are way outmatched. Jonathan instead, trusted the Lord.
Did you see it? Three times in this scene,
he expressed faith in Yahweh.
Look at it. Verse six.
He says, it may be that the Lord will work for us,
for nothing can hinder the Lord from saving
by many or by few.
Verse 10, he says, the Lord has given them into our hands.
And then verse 12, the Lord has given them into the
hand of Israel.
You see, Jonathan, his trust again, counter to his father.
Jonathan trusted the Lord to bring the victory.
That was his faith.
He didn't look around and see the massive army as a threat.
Jonathan knew that his God was all powerful.
He'd come through before he'd delivered them before.
So he surely would, again,
he's witnessed God's faithfulness.
He'll see it again. He knew it.
And so Jonathan goes and instigates the battle.
Well, the Philistines of course panicked,
which would get the attention of Saul
and his men back on their side of the ravine,
which is actually what we see next.
'cause. Watch this. Verse 16
and the watchmen of Saul in Gibbon
and in of Benjamin, looked
and behold the multitude
of Philistines was dispersing here and there.
And then Saul said to the people who were with him, count
and see who has gone from us.
And when they had counted, behold Jonathan
and his armor bearer were not there.
So naturally Saul looks at this
and says, somebody's up to something who left?
Who did it? And watch what Saul does.
Then in response to that,
and as I read this, remember
what we witnessed Saul do last week when he had the
offerings and the whole thing, he offered the offering
not with the right heart.
He didn't really want to follow God.
He just felt like he had to watch what Saul does.
Next verse 18.
So Saul said to Aja, I remember that was the priest
bring the arc of God here for the arc of God went at
that time with the people of Israel.
Now, while Saul was talking to the priest,
the tumult in the camp
of the Philistines increased more and more.
So Saul said to the priest, withdraw your hand.
Here's what was happening here.
It, it seems like Saul was trying
to get a vision from the Lord by doing this with the arc
and with the priest because the priest had a way of,
of putting his hand near the arc and,
and trying to get a vision from God and,
and seeing an oracle kind of a thought and vision
and feeling to say, here's what God wants us to do.
That was what was happening here.
But what Saul was doing with that was essentially, again,
using it as a superstitious way to discern what God wants
to hear God and and get God on his side in a way.
And we know it was superstitious
that he's using this right thing to seek God.
But we know it was superstitious
'cause he didn't even finish it.
He sees the battles getting stronger.
And so he says, stop that and we're doing something else.
Watch what he does next. Verse 20, they move on their own.
Saul and all the people who were with him rallied
and went into the battle
and behold every Philistine sword was against his fellow.
And there was very great confusion.
Now when you read that,
it sure seems like things are going well.
The Philistines are so confused by all this
that they're killing each other in some way as well.
So man, okay, then you take verse 21, not only that,
verse 21 says the, the Hebrews who had been
with the Philistines before that time, who had gone up
before them into the camp even, they also turned to be
with the Israelites who were with Saul and Jonathan.
So there was a group of people who revolted earlier, went
to join the Philistines.
They said, man, I'm not being a part of Israel anymore.
I'm gonna go with the Philistines.
That was part of what was happening.
They were coming back onto the right side of things.
Not only that, verse 22,
likewise, when all the men
of Israel who'd hidden themselves in the hill country heard
that the Philistines were fleeing, they too followed hard
after them in the battle.
So all those guys that ran away to begin with
saw the battle was being successful.
They came down and said, we're in it.
We're getting courageous.
Now, the victories on our side,
it sure seems like the tides have turned.
Maybe Saul will be the one
to finally get this right, to defeat the Philistines,
to finally obey God, to save the kingship.
Seems like that's where it's going except
for the way verse 23 reads.
Look at it with me. It says, so the Lord
saved Israel that day
and the battle passed beyond Beth Haven,
and it'll continue on into the next couple weeks.
But think about it. Who actually got the credit
for the victory here?
Was it Saul who, who made some headway in this battle
and it, it took him a while to catch on,
but he got caught off guard initially.
Was he the one who got credit for it? No.
Was it even Jonathan? Right.
Jonathan who initiated obedience.
He said, we need to defeat the Philistines. God said.
So he seemed very king like in his attitude and his faith.
Was it Jonathan who got the credit?
No, it was the Lord.
Yahweh who got the credit for the victory here.
God saved the Israelites here.
No one else did.
God saved them.
And listen, this is so critical
that the narrator recorded it this way
because if it reads any other way,
we might miss some important pieces of this narrative.
But because it says God saved them, it takes our minds
to a couple things here.
We remember that Israel was surrounded by this enemy
and it felt like a hopeless situation.
We remember that Israel only had a couple hundred guys
and they had farm tools for weapons.
We remember that when Jonathan defeated just 20
of the Philistine men, it sent the rest of the whole army
into a panic, which by the way, God helped a little bit
by sending an earthquake to increase the panic as they went.
We also remember that that verse 20 says,
every Philistine sword was against his fellow, meaning
they were killing each other.
They were so confused by everything, which is something
by the way, that God did multiple times throughout the Old
Testament, Gideon, with judges.
We see it even earlier in one Samuel,
that God would create such chaos that they couldn't help
but kill each other in that enemy army.
We remember all those things
because it says that God got the credit.
Saul didn't get the credit because we're about
to see him get replaced in the next couple chapters.
This was all leading up to Saul losing his kingship.
He didn't get the credit. But the fact
that God did get the credit is meant to remind us
that there is only one true king
and that he is actually all that we need in our lives.
That's what this is supposed to show us.
We're looking for a king, a savior. We don't need one.
We've got one. Amen.
So again, like I said, this battle will continue,
this things will continue.
Saul and Jonathan continue to get contrasted.
We'll see new lineage come up in the next few weeks.
But we've asked this question every week, okay,
how do those principles play out in our daily lives?
This moves us forward, teaches us a lot about what happened.
But how are we to apply any of these principles today?
What do we learn and how can we apply it in our context?
These were ancient occurrences, but
but what does it do for us?
How does it apply today?
Again, there can always be a few more you'd find.
But the first principle is that we,
we often see God use us
to accomplish his work.
God often uses us
Here's, here's the foundational truth.
God could have done all of this by himself, right?
He could have done absolutely all of this by himself.
We've already seen it even in First Samuel, right?
Verses uh, chapters four through six, the arc
of God travels
through the Philistine area just bringing plagues.
And people are, are overwhelmed by its presence
and they, they get frogs and boils all kinds of stuff.
Like we had nothing to do with that.
Israel had nothing to, it was God by himself.
First Samuel, chapter seven.
The Lord sent thunder to confuse the Philistines back then
so that they would begin defeating themselves.
By the way, when you hear thunder
today, don't get confused, right?
It's still just we're okay.
But that's what happened back then in
we have to remember that God doesn't actually
need us for anything.
Acts 17 is clear, right? We don't need to feed him.
We don't need to provide for him. He provides for us.
So that's the foundational truth.
God doesn't need us for anything yet.
He often chooses to work through us to accomplish
what He's ordained to happen.
When you think about Jonathan, Jonathan
was God's vessel to
initiate the battle against the Philistines.
God used the Israelite army
to bring judgment on the Philistines.
Again, he doesn't have to use us,
but he graciously chooses to use us.
Just think about it today,
God could just sovereignly on his own,
save someone from their sin in their room by themselves.
Nobody involved. God could do it.
But Romans 10 says, he uses you
or he uses me to proclaim gospel hope to that person.
So they believe he doesn't have to,
but what a privilege to be able
to share the gospel of someone and see them.
Believe He could just grow someone's
spiritually in their faith.
He could just have them grow.
But he often uses you
or uses me to hold them accountable, to encourage them,
to pray for them, to answer questions for them,
to help them understand the Bible.
Like that's what he does. That's how he works.
He doesn't have to, but what a privilege it is to be able
to be included in someone's growth process.
He could just make someone feel welcomed here on a Sunday.
Like you just walk in here and, and just feel this warmth
and this greeting and all that.
But, but he doesn't do that.
He chooses to use you
and me as vessels of his mercy to someone
so they feel welcomed, they feel greeted,
they feel warm here.
Like this is a safe place for them here.
Like he doesn't have to use us,
but he chooses to use us for that.
It's those simple things, but it's also bigger things.
He could free a person
from being trafficked,
but he chooses to use someone committed to justice to see
that happen and go for it and and fight for it.
And as I say that, listen, as I wrote that one,
I am right there with you
that there are times I don't understand why God doesn't just
do things like that on his own.
Why does he allow that to continue?
Like I, there's questions I have, I don't understand that.
But here's what I know for certain.
I don't know the answer to that. But here's why.
I know for certain, he has given me commands to obey,
to do justice, to love mercy, to walk humbly with my God,
those kind of things, right?
He's given me commands to obey.
And in his sovereignty, he works through my obedience.
He works through my willingness to get involved.
He works through my growth of my faith
and my actions to say, I'm gonna live this out.
I'm gonna obey what he says. I'm gonna do
what he wants me to do.
That's how he works in the world.
That's why when I asked the question at the beginning,
do you feel worthless to God?
That's why, for those of you who do feel worthless to God,
hear me, you're not.
You are not worthless to God.
Every single one of us has the privilege
of seeing God use our talents, our history,
our passions, our obedience.
We have the privilege of watching him use that for his glory
and for other people's good.
When you seek justice,
and that's what comes of it, that's good for
that person, right?
As you obeyed God, he used you to deliver.
He used you to preach the gospel
to someone to see them save.
He used you to help someone grow in their faith.
He used you to make someone who's given it their last shot
today on Sunday to make them finally feel welcome here.
And they say, okay, I'm gonna give another shot.
He graciously uses our lives to bless others,
to accomplish his work, to bring his kingdom
to bear on earth.
And listen, I'm talking about your life too.
Everyone of you, it says Grace.
It's a privilege that he's included us in the process.
So, so the question is,
how are you opening your hands in your life saying,
God, I'm all yours.
What? What do you want? I'm yours.
How do I obey you? How do I follow you? How do I seek you?
First, your righteousness.
And I want to, but I wanna be used by you.
Whatever that means. He wants
to use you and me to accomplish his will on this earth.
We've gotta be open-handed about
how he does that in our lives.
But, but we have to remember the second principle
as we say, that it has to be done in the spirit
of this second principle, that as the Lord calls us
to action, we must go in faith
as the Lord calls us to action.
We must go in faith
because Saul was called to action,
but he didn't go in faith, right?
Jonathan did though. And what did God do
with Jonathan's faith?
God initiated the victory through Jonathan's faith.
Jonathan trusted that nothing can hinder the Lord from
saving by many people or by few people.
Jonathan trusted that God could do that.
And so God used that to show himself off in big ways.
Now, I wanna be clear, 'cause I'm not saying
that somehow we can manipulate God through our faith,
that we can get him to do what we selfishly want him to do
if we just believe enough.
No, that's not what I'm talking about.
Because God does what He does regardless of us.
He does what he will do.
What I'm talking about is us standing firm on the nature
and character of God.
That's where confident faith comes from.
If you look at people in history around the world
who are in incredibly difficult situations, have faced
persecution, burned at the stake, whatever it is,
like all these things, where did their confidence
and faith come from?
It came from knowing the nature and character of God.
It's a solid, strong belief that God is who he says he is.
And he will do what he says he will do.
That's where that kind of faith comes from.
You wonder like how, what would I be like if I'm faced with
whatever is coming persecution?
What would I, how would I respond?
How you know is how do you believe
that God is who he says he is?
And He will do what he says he will do. Do you believe that?
Even when we can't see it in the moment,
even when that army think about it with
with their story here, right?
Even with the army completely surrounding us.
Faith says, we believe God
says he's gonna bring the victory.
Hebrews 11, one says it really well.
Faith is the assurance of things hoped for the conviction
of things not seen.
Listen, if you can see the way out,
that doesn't take any faith, right?
If you're walking blind through some situation,
it takes faith to know
that you're being led the right direction.
Faith shows up when you only have a couple hundred guys left
when you got farm tools for weapons.
But you know what God has said?
And you know that God said, attack the Philistines.
And Jonathan said, all right, I'm in. Let's go.
That's faith. And so listen, I know life
might seem overwhelming at times.
Like it might seem like the enemy is winning in your life
or in the world around us.
It might seem like that's true.
You might be tempted to bail
because it seems like God is late to the party.
Or even worse, he's not good as he comes,
you might be tempted to bail.
Don't believe it. Keep going back
to the promises of God's word to who he says he is, to
what He says he will do to the
promises he makes in his word.
And stand firm on that.
Continue to pray. Continue to serve, continue to obey,
continue to do what God's called you to do.
All of that in faith
because you know God will do his work.
It may not be on your timeline,
probably won't be on your timeline,
but you know God's gonna do it.
You know he's promised and he will because of who he is.
Because here's the third principle today
that battle you face, it ultimately belongs to the Lord.
Any battle and the final battle,
it ultimately belongs to the Lord.
Listen, if God is not behind something,
it doesn't matter how big your army is,
it will not succeed.
But if God is behind something, then no matter
how small your army is, it cannot fail.
Amen. Right? That's what Romans 8 31 says.
If God is for us, then who can be against us?
'cause remember, it wasn't Saul, it wasn't Jonathan.
It wasn't big uh, weapons.
It wasn't a massive army that saved Israel that day.
Who was it? It was God who saved Israel.
Now, he called Saul and Jonathan to play a part in that.
Absolutely. But all the credit went to the Lord.
That is just as true in your life and in my life today.
Anything good that I have comes from him.
Any victory or healing you've seen in your life is
all from his powerful hands
that ought to keep us the most humble people on the planet,
that we can't do anything.
John 15 five, apart from him.
Because the truth and the depth of this reality is this.
Not only is he the daily warrior
that we need in all the battles we face, everything,
he is the one fighting the battles.
He ultimately won the most important battle
that we could ever face.
That battle against sin
and death that leads to our separation from him forever.
Yes,
Yes. See, that's a
battle that some
of these battles we face in our
daily lives, we can overcome.
We can win, we can do that.
I've done that too many times in my life
that I've leaned on myself
and my strength to overcome whatever I'm facing.
That is a battle that you and I could never win on our own.
That enemy too strong, too overwhelming, too deep,
but nothing is impossible for the Lord
who sent his son to live, die,
and resurrect in our place to defeat that enemy
that we could never defeat.
And he defeated that enemy completely on his own,
didn't need us, couldn't use us, just did it on his own so
that when we place our faith in him
and his work for us, we are given
that eternal victory once and for all.
There's no other way we can get there.
But he said, I want it for you.
You see how joyful that should make us church.
You see how life-giving, that is
the battle we could never fight on our own.
He won it for us. And he will give us the victory
because he's won that battle for us.
And since he's won it, then why do we worry about anything
else that happens in this life?
Like if he won that one that lasts forever?
Why are we worried about political upheaval?
Why are we worried about financial swings in our lives?
Why are we worried about nation rising against nation?
Why are we worried even about death?
Amen. None of that
can sway us because if you are
his by faith, you are under his victory banner.
And that's, that's not like conditional.
That's not like, man, if whoever wins the election
or whoever's got the bigger army,
whoever, it's none of that.
It's already printed.
The victory banner is his. He is your hero.
He is your king, he is your savior.
So we don't have to be swayed by anything else in this life.
Let's believe that together though.